der doppelgänger mord von ingolstadt und
dass das sind exklusive aufnahmen einer
überwachungskamera die die frau zeigen
die ich hinter diesem mord stehen soll
von der die polizei 24 stunden lang
dachte dass sie die tote sei die aber
legt und die eben einen mord eingefädelt
haben soll es ist ein sehr schwieriger
fall wir klären sie auf darum geht seine
frau 23 jahre alt wird tot im auto
gefunden erstochen niedergemetzelt es
soll shaban k sein doch dann kommt
heraus dass ist sie gar nicht das ist
eine doppelgängerin sieht ihr zum
verwechseln ähnlich und plötzlich ist
die vermeintlich tote hier rechts im
bild unter mordverdacht und sitzt jetzt
im knast
diese neuen überwachungsbilder könnten
jetzt aufschluss geben im mysteriösen
doppelgänger mord von ingolstadt die
aufnahmen einer pizzeria zeigen die
inzwischen festgenommene shaban k
das ist passiert vergangene woche
dienstag die eltern von sarah banker
sind in großer sorge um ihre tochter
suchen ingolstadt nach ihr ab und finden
sie schließlich
blutüberströmt auf der rückbank ihres
mercedes so glauben sie zumindest
doch dann stellt sich heraus die tote
frau auf dem rücksitz ist nicht ihre
tochter die obduktion ergibt bei der
toten handelt es sich um khadija m sie
sieht die scharia bahncard zum
verwechseln ähnlich eine doppelgängerin
das blatt dreht sich auf einmal wird er
aber als tatverdächtige festgenommen
ebenso skierka bei dem shaban
unterschlupf gesucht hat kurz vor ihrer
festnahme wurde shaban k noch in
besagter pizzeria gesehen laut des
inhabers war sie aufgelöst begann zu
weinen und bat darum zu telefonieren da
ihr handy kaputt sei gegen 22 uhr sein
zwei autos vorgefahren
zwei euro gekommen und dann hatte
gesucht hatte uns gefragt wie sie frau
aber wir die frau ist gerade
und hatte dann hinterher gelaufen und da
ging ungefähr zehn meter um meter dann
hat die frau gesehen dann hat er die
frau autobahn und mitgenommen wer war
weiß nichts dazu kommt am tag danach
fand der besitzer ein kaputtes handy vor
seinem restaurant ist es das telefon von
shara banker bild recherchen bringen
weitere einzelheiten ans licht guardia
wurde mit 55 messerstichen in den
oberkörper getötet
der tatort des mordfalls wohl gar nicht
ingolstadt sondern heilbronn in baden
württemberg ein mordfall viele offene
fragen war die frau auf den
überwachungsvideos wirklich shaban
fraglich auch warum schavans eltern ihre
tochter in dem auto vermuteten denn die
scheiben des mercedes waren verdunkelt
von außen war nicht zu sehen dass eine
leiche in dem auto lag zudem hätten
schavans eltern erkennen müssen dass es
nicht ihre tochter ist entgegen erster
informationen war das gesicht durch die
55 messerstiche nicht unkenntlich
außerdem wer waren die männer die
scharia bahn chaos der pizzeria mit
namen der mysteriöse doppelgänger mord
ein kriminalfall der deutschland in atem
hält und
weiterhin viele offene fragen mit
zugeschaltet ist unser reporter jörg
völkerling jagte versuchst all diese
spuren der wie puzzleteile
zusammenzusetzen der recherchiert seit
tagen ist auch in der pizzeria was wir
uns einmal zusammen in dieser fall
gewinnt hier von stunde zu stunde heute
muss man sagen an mehr dynamik
die als journalistin müssen natürlich
auch dieses mosaik zusammensetzen die
einzelnen teile zusammen suchen und ein
zufall führte mich daneben gestern abend
denn diese pizzeria und ich zeigte den
besitzer das foto von shaban und guckte
das an mit seinen mitarbeitern war sich
sicher ja die frau war also am mittwoch
hier bei uns sie hat sich etwas
eigenartig verhalten wie sich dann auf
diesen überwachungskamera bildern auch
sehen ließ sie hat bat darum mein herr
ein handy zu bekommen telefonieren zu
dürfen weil ja das handy kaputt sei sie
können ihre sim-karte nicht benutzen sie
hat dann das handy von dem pizzabäcker
bekommen hat zwei nummern angerufen um
20 57 21 o2 hat sms geschrieben die sie
danach gelöscht hat und dann saß die vor
der pizzeria hat geweint hat offenbar
gewartet dass jemand abholt und man muss
sich einfach die die zeitachse
vergegenwärtigen dass war 24 stunden
nachdem die leiche ihrer doppelgängerin
dort aufgefunden worden war von ihren
eigenen eltern die die leiche für ihre
tochter sharon dabei war sie
quicklebendig wie man auf diesen
aufnahmen sieht und ja was hat sie
geplant hat sie den start in ihr neues
leben an dieser stelle geplant das ist
ja die theorie die die
staatsanwaltschaft an vorderster stelle
im moment verfolgt jedenfalls sicher ist
das sind die letzten schritte von shaban
karin freiheit um 21 55 wurde sie
festgenommen
welche spuren sie momentan am meisten
verfolgt das ist ja angesprochen es gibt
zwei theorien zum einen wollte sich
diese frau ein neues leben aufbauen
einfach verschwinden und dafür wurde
eine doppelgängerin ermordet oder aber
sind diese frauen und auch männer
irgendwie miteinander so verwandelt dass
es zu eifersucht dass es zu neid dass es
zu einer art beziehungstat kommen konnte
also die umfeld ermittlungen bei den
opfern bei dem opfern bei den tätern das
ist momentan im fokus steht im fokus der
kripo sowohl in ingolstadt als auch in
heilbronn wir sind ja hier in eppingen
ein kleines städtchen zwischen heilbronn
und heidelberg wo khadija
herstammt ihr hat sie ihre träume bei
tik tok hochgeladen von der großen
weiten welt mega wollte sie noch
besuchen und jetzt steht in den trauer
kommentaren dass diese reise ist ja wohl
nicht mehr vergönnt
man hat gleich nachdem die identität
fest stand natürlich bei ihren der
wohnung hier geschaut aber da war
offenbar nicht zu finden also kein
tatort kein blut jetzt sucht die polizei
tatsächlich mit einem zeugenaufruf nach
hinweisen nach leuten die diesen
mercedes s-klasse dunkel mit
verdunkelten heckscheiben am vergangenen
dienstag genau vor einer woche hier in
eppingen gesehen hat die theorie ist
wurde katia vielleicht schon hier
getötet sind die beiden tatverdächtigen
schavan und der kosovo albaner dann mit
der leiche nach ingolstadt gefahren oder
wurde khadija erst dort getötet heute
hat die polizei mit der
bereitschaftspolizei nochmal das den
donauufer bereich in unmittelbarer nähe
zum tatort abgesucht man sucht
persönliche gegenstände des opfers die
wohl fehlen
das alles soll also beitragen am ende
dieses puzzle zusammenzusetzen und
diesen ganz mysteriösen merkwürdige fall
doch noch aufzuklären
[Musik]